und jetzt das heute journal
[Musik]
heute abend in stralsund angela merkel
anlasses seite nun doch noch einmal
wahlkampf in ihrem eigenen alten
wahlkreis aber nicht mehr für sie selbst
bald hat sie das hinter sich
guten abend es ist ja tatsächlich so ist
sicher erst jetzt so richtig ins
bewusstsein dass eine kanzlerin
dämmerung ansteht wenn eine während sich
die welt x-mal verändert immer da ist
immer im zentrum immer auf dem schirm 16
jahre lang dann wird sie unweigerlich zu
einer konstante wie man sich nicht mehr
so leicht weg denken kann nicht mal als
gegner ist es dann doch soweit ist ganz
am schluss auf den moment haben
strategische köpfe vor allem bei der spd
von anfang an gesetzt als spd und olaf
scholz noch weit hinten lagen und nur
eine hoffnung sie über wasser hielt das
nochmal neue beweglichkeit entstehen
wird vielleicht in ihre richtung willen
handeln bewusst wird dass das merkel
kapitel sowieso zu ende gelesen ist
historisch wird sich später mal weisen
eine erstaunliche geschichte allemal
eine politische eine persönliche hat das
feldhoff kennt sie von a bis z
angela merkel war immer die untypische
kanzlerin sie war die erste ostdeutsche
die erste frau im amt und sie hatte eine
ganz eigensinnigen sicht auf sich selbst
sie sieht sich nicht wirklich als teil
des establishments also das nennt man
mal etwas kuriose züge an dass einer
ihrer frühen vertrauten hat dann mal als
ich ein bundeskanzlerin war gesagt frau
merkel sie sind doch establishment er
erzählte mir dann dass sie eben ganz
komisch geguckt hatte angela merkel war
immer die frau mit der distanz distanz
zu den parteifreunden wir am anfang
einfach nicht ernst nehmen wollte sie
hat distanz zu ihrem amt distanz zu
ihrem volk vielleicht ergebnis einer
jugend in der ddr und einem spätstart in
die westdeutsch geprägten politik
angela hat sich glaube ich demokratie
und auch marktwirtschaft erarbeitet wie
ein wissenschaftler das tut sie hat das
eben von optiker auf studiert merkels
weg durch die instanzen ist auch immer
ein weg durch krisen der sturz kohls und
ihr machtzuwachs gehen hand in hand
damals und sie erst das partei denkmal
und dann den eigenen parteichef zur
seite merkel und der kampf gegen die
männer in der union wird zu einem
eigenen kapitel
angela merkel ist starke politische
führen und das bedeutet dass auch viele
am ende nicht die politische führung
übernehmen weil sie sie hat und mag sein
dass sie nicht alle die zugetraut habe
aber sie hat sie das wenn man sie
unterschätzt hat man verloren
angela merkel gelingt in den krisen
immer der aufstieg in der finanz und
eurokrise wird sie zur mächtigsten und
meist kasten frau europas in der
flüchtlingskrise durch einen einzigen
satz zur hoffnungsträgerin
wir haben so vieles geschafft wir
schaffen das und die krise die ausgelöst
wird durch ein us wahl macht sie zur
führerin der westlichen welt
ich glaube sie hat keine hohe meinung
von dem volk das hier regiert
paradoxerweise war sie ja nur gerade
deshalb wenn man so erfolgreich weil die
deutschen sie gewählt haben als garanten
der stabilität und das sich nach
möglichkeit nichts ändern
merkel ist aber auch die kanzlerin der
verpassten chancen analytisch immer ganz
weit vorn politisch oft gestrandet
beim klima proklamiert sie lange zeit
ehrgeizige ziele umsetzen prinzip
deutlich zu wenig in der pandemie zeigt
sich dass so vieles bei musterschüler
deutschland nur fassade ist die
gesundheitsvorsorge hinkt hinterher die
digitalisierung der schulen wurde
schlicht nicht angepackt auch nichts tun
scheint teil des erfolges
dinge die sozusagen zu risikobehaftet
sind macht sie dann halt einfach nicht
sonst wäre sie wahrscheinlich nicht 16
jahre kanzlerin geblieben die ära merkel
geht zu ende und ihr erbe ist vielfach
ein trümmerhaufen die wunschnachfolgerin
gescheitert deren nachfolger strauchelt
ebenfalls wochenlang hatte merkel sich
geweigert für armin laschet wahlkampf zu
machen symptomatisch für ihr verhältnis
zu ihrer eigenen cdu
bezeichnen war ja ihr auftritt in der
sommerpressekonferenz wo sie zuerst
sagte die partei die mir nahe steht und
dann fiel hier irgendwie nach kurzem
nachdenken doch noch einen dass sie da
ja mitglied ist
heute abend macht angela merkel dann
doch was sie so lange vermeiden wollte
wahlkampf für armin laschet im
strömenden regen von stralsund ihrem
alten wahlkreis ein letztes aufbäumen
ein letzter dienst an der partei
der bundesrat ist die wahl los jetzt
musst du unbedingt bei tageslicht und
soll ich da hin wieder hier
[Applaus]
16 jahre lang war angela merkel
kanzlerin dabei hat sie das land mehr
verändert als sie wohl selbst vermuten
würde
und jetzt ist heute doch noch ein
bisschen wahlkampf mit kanzlerin aber
immer noch fast ohne kanzlerinnen bonus
wahlkampf von hinten die spd liegt vorne
seine unerträgliche lage für die macht
gewohnte macht verwöhnte cdu sie würde
wählern gerne klar machen oder einreden
dass olaf scholz das trojanische pferd
ist das eine unberechenbare gefährliche
linke in die mitte der gesellschaft und
ins kanzleramt rollt aber diese
erzählung zündet offenbar nicht so
richtig weil die spd etwas gelernt hat
was sie jahrzehntelang nicht konnte
einheit nach außen vielleicht sogar nach
innen wie war und wie stabil das ist
wird sich wie immer erst zeigen wenn die
partei x an der macht ist im moment
jedenfalls funktioniert es beobachtet
lars bohnsack
schlange stehen für ein foto mit dem
kanzlerkandidaten es sind gerade
ungewöhnliche zeiten für die spd olaf
scholz unterwegs sie niedersachsen und
700 wohlgesonnene sind gekommen der
kanzlerkandidat zieht auf den plätzen
wie in den umfragen und doch ist das
rennen noch nicht gelaufen aber das will
ich auch sagt gewählt am sonntag
dass der nächste kanzler oder chance
heißt er muss es eine kreuzer spd
machten tatsächlich ist der wahlkampf
von anfang an auf olaf scholz
zugeschnitten die partei kommt kaum vor
denn es ist scholz der eine schwache spd
die vor wenigen wochen noch bei 15
prozent wie einbetoniert schien mit
seinen persönlichen werten aus dem
demoskopischen tief gezogen hat die wahl
fällt zwischen armin laschet auf der
einen seite und olaf scholz auf der
anderen seite und uns war von vornherein
klar es wird ein personalisierter
wahlkampf ist wird ein kanzler wahlkampf
und deswegen haben wir gesagt stellen
für olaf scholz auch in den mittelpunkt
dieser kampagne comex wirecard
staatsanwaltschaftliche besucher in
seinem ministerium alles scheint
irgendwie an olaf scholz ab zu perlen
vor zwei jahren noch wollten sie ihn
nicht als vorsitzenden haben in der spd
jetzt gibt er als kanzlerkandidat den
kurs der partei vor die einen sagen er
habe die spd gekapert andere nennen das
arbeitsteilung das land zu führen die
partei zu führen das sind tatsächlich
zwei ganz verschiedene aufgaben
unterschiedliche aufgaben die auch
unterschiedliche kompetenzen verlangen
wir sind in dieser arbeitsteilung glaube
ich sehr erfolgreich und sehr zufrieden
mit der entscheidung
und dennoch die geschlossenheit der spd
bleibt auffallend keine querschüsse wie
im vergangenen wahlkämpfen keine
diskussionen um den kurs der partei und
das obwohl der kanzlerkandidatin erfolg
in der mitte sucht parteiführung und spd
linke ziehen mit denn scholz erfolg sich
hat ihre mandate
also ich glaube die frage dass diese
gesellschaft zusammenhalten muss und
dass wir deswegen eine starke mitte
brauchen ist überhaupt keine frage von
rechts und links sondern die
sozialdemokratie lebt davon dass wir das
gemeinsame denken und da gibt es
überhaupt keinen unterschied zwischen
olaf scholz und mir wie lange aber wird
der burgfrieden halten zwingen die
linken in der spd scholz nach der wahl
doch noch zu rot rot grün wenn es ein
wahlsieg der spd gibt dann geht der mit
olaf scholz nach hause und dann wird
olaf scholz auch natürlich entscheiden
können welches bündnis er installiert es
wird nicht einfach werden aber gegen den
willen des erfolgreichen
kanzlerkandidaten wird man keine
koalition durchsetzen können das alles
gilt natürlich nur für den erfolgsfall
commons scholz und die spd nicht an die
macht könnte sich die neue harmonie
unter den genossen ganz schnell als
trügerisch erweisen
wulf schmiese hat nachher im
heute-journal update kurz noch ein paar
fragen an olaf scholz nur 30 am ende des
tages ein schier unvorstellbares
verbrechen lässt heute fragen wie es so
weit kommen konnte und was zu tun ist
dass sich so etwas nie wiederholt im
rheinland-pfälzischen idar oberstein ist
ein tankstellen kassiererin einem streit
um die masken pflicht getötet worden
politiker und experten äußern sich
bestürzt die tat sei ein einzelfall aber
auch hinweis auf eine zunehmende
radikalisierung der
korona leugner ein 49 jähriger war von
dem kassierer gebeten worden einen mund
nasen schutz zu tragen der student hatte
als aushilfe in der tankstelle
gearbeitet
offenbar aus wut über die masken pflicht
erschoss der täter den 20 jährigen bei
seiner vernehmung soll der mann
ablehnung der chor ohne einschränkungen
insgesamt geäußert haben
verfassungsschützer sehen die tat als
konsequenz rechtsextremistischer
verschwörungs fantasien heftige kritik
an der querdenker bewegung kommt von
unions kanzlerkandidat laschet ebenso
wie die kanzlerkandidatin der grünen
baerbock forderte er sich gegen den
zunehmenden hass zu stellen dem heute
journal update sagte spd-kanzlerkandidat
scholz ich finde dass da für uns die
aufgabe darin besteht dass wir alle
überzeugen dass sie von solchen
eigenwilligen haltungen in ihrem kopf
davon kommen wir müssen auch gegen
rechtsextremismus und gegen all
diejenigen vorgehen die merkwürdige
ideologien haben die unter dem stichwort
querdenker in diesem land diskutiert
werden
in hamburg dürfen geimpfte und genesene
ab samstag neben restaurants und
kultureinrichtungen auch clubs und
fußball stadien ohne maske und abstand
nutzen somit können dann stadien bis auf
den letzten platz besetzt werden das 2g
modell gilt in der hansestadt seit ende
august bundesweit sinken die korona
zahlen weiter das rk ii meldet
4664 neuinfektionen
1661 weniger als vergangenen dienstag
die sieben tage incidents geht ebenfalls
zur unter auf aktuell
68,5 die hass plakate der rechtsextremen
kleinstpartei der dritte weg in zwickau
müssen nun doch abgehängt werden das
sächsische oberverwaltungsgericht in
bautzen wie es ein anderslautendes
urteil zurück und urteilte die plakate
mit dem schriftzug hängt die grünen
erfüllten den tatbestand der
volksverhetzung
auch die facebook seite der neonazi
kleinste teil bleibt gesperrt so ein
beschluss des bundesverfassungsgerichts
wegen eines mutmaßlich bewaffneten
passagiers in einem reisebus ist die
autobahn 9 südlich von nürnberg derzeit
in beiden richtungen voll gesperrt
nach angaben der polizei befinden sich
die beiden busfahrer und der verdächtige
fahrgast in dem bus alle übrigen
passagiere seien im freien auf dem
seitenstreifen eine verhandlungsgruppe
der polizei ist im einsatz ob es sich um
eine geiselnahme handelt ist noch unklar
die vereinten nationen haben die usa
wegen der massenabschiebung von
migranten nach haiti kritisiert in
vielen fällen gebe es keine
einzelfallprüfung empörung haben in den
usa diese bilder vom einsatz berittener
us grenzpolizisten ausgelöst offenbar
wollen die polizisten die menschen
vertreiben derzeit versuchen tausende
flüchtlinge vor allem aus haiti die
grenze zwischen mexiko und den usa zu
überqueren zwischenzeitlich hatten mehr
als 15.000 menschen unter einer brücke
aus
als die welt nach fürchterlichen erde
umspannenden kriegen den trümmern lag
entstand aus verzweiflung ein traum von
einer menschheit die nie wieder krieg
geführt weil ein welt parlament
vereinten nationen einen ausgleich der
interessen schafft friedliche lösung in
diesem traum steht heute im besten fall
noch das ritual der jährlichen
un-vollversammlung mächtiger aller
herren länder kommen zusammen und reden
jetzt wieder in new york die alten
ideale werden da wieder beschworen auch
von präsident biden auf dem vor kurzem
noch viel hoffnung lag und der sich
jetzt mit einer demütigenden niederlage
in afghanistan und mit neuen fronten im
rest der welt beschäftigt bündnisse
beschwört während der alten verbündeten
auf die füße tritt wie seinerzeit
dolmetschern johannes hano berichtet aus
new york es war joe biden als erster
auftritt vor den vereinten nationen als
us präsident wird sich amerika neu
positionieren weil die frage die alle
schon im vorfeld beschäftigte
während der präsident noch auf dem weg
war war der un-generalsekretär im saal
dabei die weltgemeinschaft wachzurütteln
einem here to sound die allah ich bin
hier um alarm zu schlagen die welt muss
endlich aufwachen wir stehen am abgrund
und wir gehen in die falsche richtung
nie war unsere welt bedrohter und nie so
gespalten wir sind konfrontiert mit um
ihr krisen als jemals zuvor zu unseren
lebzeiten
die weltweite kurve pandemie die
wachsende schere zwischen arm und reich
und die sich immer weiter verschärfen
die klimakrise könnten die welt über den
abgrund hinausführen als joe biden dann
als rednerpult rat war die botschaft
klar amerika ist beck amerika ist zurück
anstatt die kriege der vergangenheit zu
führen werden wir unsere augen auf die
schlüsselfragen richten die unsere
gemeinsame zukunft bestimmen werden
die pandemie beenden klimakrise angehen
die veränderung der globalen
machtverhältnisse zu managen und die
regeln der welt zu formen in handels
cyber und technologiefragen
und er machte deutlich in welcher region
in zukunft amerikas prioritäten liegen
die vereinigten staaten ihren fokus
verschieben auf die regionen wie den
indopazifischen raum die besonders
wichtig sind heute und in der zukunft
werden wir das mit unseren verbündeten
tuch
er wollte sich dabei eng mit nato und
europäische union abstimmen sagte er
doch dort ist man nach dem abzug aus
afghanistan und dem hinter frankreichs
rücken 1 gefährdeten boden mit
australien nicht besonders gut auf den
us präsidenten zu sprechen gestern abend
schon machte die eu kommissionspräsident
in new york ihrer zerknirschung luft
unsere mitgliedsstaaten wurde auf eine
weise behandelt die nicht akzeptabel ist
wir wollen wissen was und warum es
passiert ist bevor wir weitermachen
können wie bisher
und der ärger sitzt tief ein für morgen
geplantes treffen der aussenminister
innen von deutschland frankreich
großbritannien und den usa wurde
kurzfristig abgesagt
europa scheint erstmal verdauen zu
müssen dass sich amerikas prioritäten
verschoben haben
damit zu unseren korrespondenten in den
hauptstädten der usa und europas immer
beginnen wir dort aus chinesischer sicht
präsentiert sich jetzt ein westen der
china angeblich eindämmen will der
darüber aber innerlich gespalten wurde
war das jetzt ein grober fehler im team
beiden oder aber das absicht
also im team beiden glaube ich wundert
man sich ein wenig dass die europäer
jetzt so überrascht tun weil der
präsident ja damals schon im wahlkampf
aber dann nach amtsantritt auch in
seinen reden auch beim g 7 und beim nato
gipfel eigentlich klar gesagt hat dass
er die große bedrohung der zukunft in
china sieht speziell in der region
indopazifik ich zitiere mal beiden aus
dem februar wir werden chinas
wirtschaftliche aggressives
erpresserisch essverhalten bekämpfen und
im april forderte er zitat eine starke
militärpräsenz im indopazifik sowie mit
der nato in europa also das wohin die
reise geht müsste eigentlich
kristallklar sein dass wie das
überrascht jetzt jeden dieses chaos beim
abzug aus afghanistan die heimlichtuerei
jetzt beim atom u boote mit australien
und unsinn beiden und auch sein
außenminister blinken ja eigentlich sehr
sehr erfahrene außenpolitiker da drängt
sich der verdacht ein stück weit auf
dass dieser ganze lärm absicht ist um
ein wirklich klares signal nach china zu
sehen man meint es ernst und auch um die
europäer wachzurütteln dass sie selber
mehr tun müssen in ihrer eigenen region
stichwort russland und dass sie sich
entscheiden müssen wo sie entstehen in
der auseinandersetzung mit china dann
besteht der ball direkt nach brüssel
florian das ist ein akzeptables
verhalten hat die
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
heute der führungsmacht vorgeworfen das
sind starke worte die man normalerweise
gegenüber russland oder peking einsetzt
hat denn frau von der leyen auch starke
möglichkeiten sich dazu wählen
naja ersten sind solche worte schon an
sich ein starkes signal zumal sich alle
europäer heute hinter frankreich
gestellt haben das dürfte man auch in
washington durchaus auch mit
der angespannten waren vernehmen
zweitens ja es gibt auch in brüssel
überlegungen was man auch als
handfestere signale in richtung
washington aussenden könnte und da
geriet heute einen termin in dem
blickfeld der nächste woche in
pittsburgh stattfinden soll nämlich ein
erstes treffen eines handels und
technologie rates der eu und der usa ein
forum wo man sich über gemeinsame
handelsfragen austauschen will in diesem
ersten termin will man eventuell in
brüssel jetzt also verschieben eine
entscheidung ist aber noch nicht
gefallen und schließlich wirft diese
aktion der usa ein schlaglicht auf die
ganz große frage dieser zeit nämlich die
der strategischen autonomien der
eigenständigkeit europas diese frage
wurde er schon häufig diskutiert und mit
vollmundigen versprechungen und zum teil
auch mit unterschriften geklärt dass in
zukunft europa mehr tut ist bisher nicht
passiert kann dass sie es mal was werden
nein der tat es hat viele dieser
sogenannten weg rufe gegeben an europa
über die man hier so gern spricht in
brüssel wenig wurde erhört das ist
diesmal anders wird da ist der
optimismus nicht sonderlich groß auch
wenn der druck tatsächlich groß ist aber
europa hat in den nächsten monaten erst
mal mit sich selbst zu tun in
deutschland steht eine voraussichtliche
langwierige regierungsbildung an und
dann folgt in frankreich im ersten
halbjahr 2022 an
präsidentschaftswahlkampf der also auch
dieses land beschäftigen wird und damit
ist die eu erst einmal für die ganz
großen reform schritte in dieser
richtung blockiert soll ja auch im
normalen leben passieren dass ein
weckruf kommt und alle liegen bleiben
dankeschön florian und hier geht es
weiter mit nachrichten nicht nur aus der
wirtschaft auch aus der wissenschaft die
bayern tech gründer arthur ashe und ugur
sahin werden gemeinsam mit der
biochemikerin katalin carico mit dem
renommierten paul ehrlich und ludwig
darmstaedter preis geehrt die um gering
carico legte mit ihrer m rna
grundlagenforschung die basis für die
schnelle corona impfstoff entwicklung
des mainzer unternehmens
der preis würdigt auch das potenzial der
technologie das tourette erstens im
kampf gegen krebs sieht und
und das seite sind als wichtige
zusätzliche säule weitere
schutzimpfungen gegen die richtigen
große
infektionserkrankungen wie zum beispiel
malaria
tuberkulose
fast jeder zweite haushalt in
deutschland heizt mit gas das könnte in
diesem winter teurer werden denn die
großhandelspreise für erdgas schwanken
stark und legen insgesamt allerdings
deutlich zu wir fragen frank bethmann
die warnungen vor einem gaspreis schock
mehren sich womit es zu rechnen ja damit
dass die gestiegenen erzeuger und
großhandelspreise spürbar durchschlagen
werden auf die verbraucherpreise da das
internetportal verivox beobachtet
bereits jetzt zahlreiche preiserhöhungen
so haben für september und oktober schon
32 regionale gasanbieter steigende
preise von durchschnittlich fast 13
prozent angekündigt was beim beheizen
eines einfamilienhauses zu mehrkosten
von
188 euro im jahr für die einfuhrpreise
für erdgas sind seit jahresanfang bis
juli um 42 prozent gestiegen gas ist auf
den energiemärkten ein knappes gut
geworden und dafür gibt es gleich
mehrere gründe
da ist zum einen die enorm gestiegene
nachfrage insbesondere die aus asien die
von den gasförderern derzeit nur
schleppend wegen zahlreichen
wartungsarbeiten an bohrinseln und
pipelines bedient werden kann zudem sind
viele gasspeicher hierzulande für diese
jahreszeit ungewöhnlich niedrig gefüllt
das gas teurer wird war gewollt
stichwort energiewende stichwort
preisaufschlag fürs imitierte co2 das
die preise für das erdgas jetzt aber so
durch die decke gehen ist insbesondere
für die chemie aber auch für die
metallindustrie ein riesenproblem beide
branchen zählen zu den größten erdgas
verbrauchern in deutschland und beide
machen wenig hoffnung die preise dürften
eher noch weiter steigen fand bethmann
vielen dank
die deutsche frauenfußball
nationalmannschaft hat ihr wm
qualifikationsspiel gegen serbien mit 5
zu 1 gewonnen vor 1600 zuschauern in
chemnitz war lehrer schüler von bayern
münchen mit vier treffern die
überragende spielerin die dfb auswahl
ist in der gruppe h nach zwei spieltagen
tabellenführer
der vulkanausbruch auf der spanischen
kanaren insel la palma richtet immer
größere schäden an weitere wenn auch
kleine erdbeben erschütterten das gebiet
um den vulkan congree vera dort bildete
sich ein weiterer riss durch den heiße
lava ausströmt die zahl der menschen die
ihre häuser verlassen mussten erhöhte
sich auf 6.000 bislang wurden mehr als
160 gebäude sowie dutzende strassen und
stromleitungen zerstört wissenschaftler
gehen davon aus dass der ausbruch noch
wochen andauern könnte
kindermund tut wahrheit kund das ist
zwar eher ein gerücht als eine
lebenserfahrung aber es gibt einen
umgekehrten effekt der sich bei
wahlkämpfen guten nutzen lässt im
journalismus alte journalistin hasen
beobachten damit neid dass politiker und
politikerinnen fragen den kindern freier
und direkter sagen wir ruhig ehrliche
antworten als den abgebrühten
journalistischen profis das phänomen
nutzen die kinderreporter von logo mit
selbstverständlicher professionalität
bei uns natürlich
eigenständig spontan unser 1 schaut
einfach zu es lohnt sich immer wieder
darum lässt länder matthey von der logo
redaktion ihre reporter für sich selbst
sprechen
es sind vor allem ihre fragen die so
unvermittelt kommen wenn ich ein tier
sein müsste dann wäre ich gerne nadler
was werden sie denn gern für 1
habe ich mir auch noch keine gedanken
hatte ich habe immer als lieblingstier
manchmal die kröte genannt eine sehr
verbunden ist ihr
aber direkt verwandeln möchte mich
eigentlich auch nicht dauerhaft
vielleicht ist es diese
unberechenbarkeit warum sich merkel in
den letzten zehn jahren ihrer
kanzlerschaft lieber keinen logo
kinderreportern mehr stellen wollte die
aktuellen spitzen kandidaten und
kandidatinnen dagegen haben sich getraut
auf den wahlplakaten sind sie ja immer
ganz grün im gesicht sind sie fan von
shrek oder warum machen sie das schon
eine gute frage das habe ich auch als
erstes gedacht als unsere werbeagentur
und sie gezeigt habt sie wollen der
nächste finanzminister werden zahlen sie
eigentlich immer mit bar oder mit karte
und lieber mit karte sie haben jetzt
zwei minuten gleich zeit die sie in
denen sie können sie jetzt deutschland
malen und zwar so wie es aussehen wird
wenn sie bundeskanzler werden
meine idee ist dass deutschland ein
bundesland ist dass wir alle gut leben
das habe ich mal so ein haus gemalt und
ein strich menschen
und ich bin
was angst denn auf lindner ach ja
nochmal
und nicht minder
jedenfalls bringen einen kinderreporter
dazu alberne sachen zu machen und sogar
olaf scholz geht richtig aus sich raus
sie sind ja eher ein ernster typ der
seine gefühle unter kontrolle hat ist
ihnen schon mal was richtig peinliches
passiert wo sie rot wurden ja
was war das stand sage ich nicht
und sie sorgen dafür dass sich politiker
selbst entlarven wir möchten wir dass
das wieder mehr deutsche volkslieder
geleert werden dass die deutsche
gedichte gelernt werden ich finde wir
müssen schon relativ viele gedichte
auswendig lernen was ist denn ihr
lieblingsgedicht eigentlich
deutschland gibt es für dich mein
lieblingsgedicht ist er muss ich jetzt
müsste ich jetzt mal überlegen wird bis
1 1 nicht wie schauen sie wenn sie
jemals so fritzsche einlädt
wir gucken sie wenn sie geblitzt werden
wenn ihnen jemand eine vegane nürnberger
rostbratwurst anbieten würde
ja das war es von den logo
kinderreportern für diese bundestagswahl
fortsetzung folgt natürlich
[Musik]
jung verwitwet und allein heißt unsere
37 grad doku hatte sie erzählt darüber
wie es ist wenn der tod ein paar viel zu
früh auseinanderreißt und eine
fassungslose junge witwe oder ein junger
bitte zurückbleiben oft mit ihren
kindern eine geschichte die schwer zu
erzählen ist aber viele familien trifft
gleich nach uns und ein kurzer nachtrag
noch zu dem zwischenfall an der a9 dem
sek einsatz dort der mutmaßlich
bewaffnete ist zwischenzeitlich
festgenommen worden mehr ist noch nicht
bekannt guten abend sagen das nur
[Musik]
genannt morgen um 21 uhr 21 ist es
soweit dann beginnt astronomische der
herbst und zur tag- und nachtgleiche
gibt es ja oft richtig kräftige stürme
herbststürme oder ein erster herz sturm
ist hier unterwegs das ist das team das
von island weiter richtung skandinavien
ziehen noch hält es abstand von
mitteleuropa aber sie sehen das am
donnerstag ist dann doch an den küsten
von nord- und ostsee richtig windig wird
in dieser nacht noch nicht da gibt es
zwar nordwestwind aber der macht sich
eigentlich nur in der osthälfte
bemerkbar und dann kann es zwischen
berlin brandenburg und dem erzgebirge
etwas regnen richtung südwesten es ist
zum teil auch klar und dann bildet sich
nebel und unter klarem himmel wird es
sehr kalt dann sinken die temperaturen
auf 7 bis 3 grad ist droht also örtlich
bodenfrost deutlich milder bleibt die
nacht hier im nordosten und an der see
bei 13 bis 19 grad die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 14 grad in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen und 21 grad ganz im
westen zum beispiel am rhein und dazu
gibt es morgen viel sonnenschein am
rhein und westlich davon richtung dort
aus sind die wolken etwas dichter
regentropfen sind aber doch die absolute
ausnahme und am donnerstag kommt dann
der herbststurm hier an den küsten von
nord- und ostsee heran bei temperaturen
von 16 bis 23 grad und zum wochenende
wird sogar noch wärmer und das sehen sie
hier am trend für berlin ganz schön
direkt nach sonntag sinken die
temperaturen aber wieder unter 20 grad
aber vielleicht wird das ein richtig
schöner herbst genannt